you know what's really sad about men
that we can't have a beautiful thought
about a woman that isn't followed by a
disgusting thought
about that same woman we're not capable
of it we can't
do one the other if you're a woman and a
guy's ever said
anything romantic to you he just left
off the second part
that would have made you sick
if you could have heard it
that's how our brains work she's an
angel
and i want her to drown in my [ __ ]
that's the closest we can get
to poetry in our hearts
we love you we really do we think you're
angels
and we want you to drown in our [ __ ]
we want to drench your angel wings that
carry you to heaven
with our sticky gooey disgusting chism
that's what we want
i'm sorry it's just the way we are
now something a little more positive for
you don't want you to think the whole
show is just negativity
this is about a festival this is my idea
for one of those big
outdoor summer festivals this is called
slugfest
this is for men only here's what you do
you get about a hundred thousand of
these
[ __ ] men you know the ones i mean
these macho [ __ ]
yeah these strutting preening posturing
hairy sweaty alpha male
jackoffs the muscle [ __ ]
you take about a hundred thousand of
these disgusting pricks
you throw them in a big dirt arena big
25-acre dirt arena
and you just let them beat the [ __ ] out
of each other
for 24 hours non-stop no food no water
just whiskey and pcp
[Applause]
and you just let them punch and pound
and kick the [ __ ] out of each other
until only one guy is left standing
then you take that guy and you put him
on a pedestal and you shoot him in the
[ __ ] head
yeah yeah
then you put the whole thing on tv
budweiser would jump at that [ __ ] in
half a minute
and guys would volunteer guys would line
up all you got to do is promise them a
small appliance of some kind
men will do anything just give them
something that plugs in the wall makes a
whirring noise
here's another male cliche these guys
would cut the sleeves off of their
t-shirts
so the rest of us can have an even more
compelling experience
of smelling their armpits i say hey
bruno
shut it down would you please you smell
like an anchovies [ __ ]
okay not
good
not good bruno and definitely not for
sharing this is the same kind of guy
that has that barbed wire
tattoo that goes all the way around the
bicep you've seen that and yeah that's
just what i need
some guy who hasn't been laid since the
bicentennial
wants me to think he's a bad
[ __ ]
because he's got a picture aha a
painting
of some barbed wire on his eyes hey
junior come around when you have the
real thing on there and squeeze that
[ __ ] on good and tight for you okay
no kidding no kidding this is the same
kind of guy if you
if you smashed him in the face eight or
nine times with a big chunk of concrete
and then beat him over the head with a
steel rod for an hour and a half you
know what
he dropped like a [ __ ] rock
like a rock here's another
guy thing that sucks these t-shirts that
say lead
follower get out of the way you ever see
that this is more of that stupid marine
corps
[ __ ] obsolete male impulses from a
hundred thousand years ago
lead follower get out of the way you
know what i do when i see that shirt
i obstruct i stand right in the guy's
path
force him to walk around he gets a
little past me i spin him around kick
him on the nuts rip off the shirt
wipe it on my ass and shove it down his
[ __ ] throat
that's what i do
yeah hey listen
that's all these marines are looking for
a good time
and speaking of tough guys i'm getting a
little tired of hearing
that after six policemen get arrested
for shoving a floor lamp up some black
guy's ass
and ripping his intestines out the
police department announces they're
going to have
sensitivity training i say hey
if you need special training to be told
not to jam a large cumbersome object of
someone else's [ __ ]
maybe you're too [ __ ] up to be on the
police force in the first place
all right this is how it works with guys
anytime you do anything remotely
sensitive heartwarming anything that's
going to make you more of a loving
caring individual
immediately all your guy friends suggest
that maybe just baby
you want to suck a dick
oh it's brutal even if you do something
smart
right like it's raining out he's got an
umbrella
what a fig oh my god
what are you afraid of the water put
your shoulders up you [ __ ]
homo jesus christ don't you pull that
thing out of your ass
oh it's brutal it doesn't even have to
make sense
you carved a pumpkin what do you do next
carve some guy's ass with your [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what are you gonna blow a
scarecrow
dude get away from me with your gay
little pumpkin
oh it's brother dude what are you a [ __ ]
is the reason why guys drop at 55 out of
[ __ ] nowhere
it's literally from five decades it's
just suppressing the urge
to like hug a puppy admit a baby's cute
say you want a cookie you just gotta
keep pushing it down like [ __ ] that i'm
not sucking dick
i'm not sucking dick
[Applause]
and then one day one day you're in a
denny's and they forget to put bananas
in your pancakes
you just have like an aneurysm and your
head slams off that sticky table
and the last thing you hear before it
all goes black is your friends go
he got bananas in his pancakes what a
bag oh my god it wasn't sweet enough
with the syrup you fairy
hey bring another one over hole and
shove it up his ass all right
cause it looks like a dick right it
looks like a dick yeah i thought it that
i said it i lost it
yeah and a man gonna be a man
a man is basically as faithful as his
options
[Applause]
that's how faithful a man is no more no
less
you see all these fat republican guys
going i would never do such a thing
this is a tragedy i'm like nobody's
trying to blow you
ain't no 20 year old girls trying to
blow orange hatch
ain't nobody trying to give newt
gingrich son
i don't give a [ __ ] you ain't never
gonna hit newt gingrich go man i wish
these hoes would back up off me
i wish they would just back the [ __ ] up
off of right now
let a player play [ __ ]
that's right it's definitely impossible
for a man to turn down sex it's
hard for a man to turn down sexy we can
stop
chasing it and even that requires some
rehab
but it's hard for a man to stop whoa
return what if it chases us we can't run
that fast
it's gonna catch us we're like oh [ __ ]
pulled a hamstring he got me got me got
me
you can't run that fast see it's easy
for women to turn down sex it ain't [ __ ]
for y'all to turn down sex
it ain't no thing for y'all to turn down
sex y'all like how come you
you know i can't you turn it down i do
it all the time i do it all the time
why can't you say no i say no see it's
easy for y'all
you know why because every woman in here
ever since she was 13
every guy you met's been trying to [ __ ]
you
that's right women are offered dick
every day every woman in here
gets off a dick at least three times a
week
three times a day [ __ ]
that's right every time a man's being
nice to you all he's doing is offering
dick that's all i am
that's all it is that's all it is
uh oh oh could i get that for you how
about some dick
could i help you with that can i help
get some dick
do you need some dick
nobody offers us [ __ ] we got to fend for
ourselves
we can't believe it when we get off
we're like damn that's my lucky day
that's right man that's right see now
this whole this whole
this whole monica lewinsky scandal a lot
of this [ __ ] is hillary's fault
that's right i said it
i said it it had to be said
somebody got to say it everybody
hillary's a hero
hillary's a hero no she ain't aquaman's
a hero
like i one time i read this this is a
thing i read
by a scientist it was it was in one of
those big science books you know
or else it was one line in usa today i
can't remember
but but it said this
it said scientists now say that a man
thinks about sex once every 7.3
seconds now now of course that's
horseshit
like how could that possibly be you know
you can't couldn't walk down the street
yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you blow your [ __ ] head off by the
second thing
and also i'm a man i don't need no
scientists telling me nothing
i know what i think once every 7.3
seconds
plus i don't like when they use decimals
like that
now i could have said once every 10 or
15 seconds
oh yeah he was a scientist
i know what i think once every 7.3
seconds i'll just be walking down the
street you know you just
you know you're like doodly doo hey
there's a building
hey look at that guy wearing cowboy
boots over there how about that
dudely dude i wonder if i should wear
cowboy boots
i'm too old for that sir
oh there's that building again
hey my ass is itchy over here
i can't scratch my ass out here in the
streets
hey willie nelson still wears cowboy
boots billy joe shaver too
most fellers must be well on three
scoring ten
anyway it's just a bunch of meaningless
gibberish that's my point
but it's not sex and then the real
time this is the amount of time that you
think about sex
every once in a while which is
not a science scientists don't like that
term
but every once in a while you think
about it and uh you know
uh like i think about every couple days
or if you're a younger man you probably
think about more you know what i mean
but then the problem becomes when you
think about it
is all you can think about you know i
mean it just encompasses your whole
brain
you know you're just like ah you're like
a
like a [ __ ] werewolf or something
like
usually you're a civilized human being
but then every couple days like
[Applause]
and then you go to your bedroom which
normally i love the bedroom it's the
most beautiful
place where you can you know finally
escape this
hellish joke we call a life and just you
know lie on your tempurpedic pillar and
dream of jelly rolls and stuff like that
but now when you're in this state you
know what i mean then you go and you're
like ah
and the things that you do in that
bedroom good
lord goddess it's beyond the imagination
of you as a civilized human being most
of the time you know what i mean you're
in there you're like
[Laughter]
your [ __ ] mind's gone your mind is
gone that's all i know
you ever actually say things that you're
doing your mind's [ __ ] so kind you're
like i am [ __ ] you
ah my [ __ ] is going aha
and the lady's like yeah i know whatever